from nick hey oh no
i don't know
hi michael me again
hi nick it's been a while i feel like
you and i have built a level of comfort
and trust so i'm going to tell you
something that i've hidden my whole life
like a secret i've kept locked away
recently i started dating again not
really for me personally it just felt
selfish not getting out there when so
many women are lonely or were turning to
lesbianism
this is where my bro to bro confession
with you begins i met this girl i spit
some game and she ended the
she ended the clothing optional
adventure before it began
because she only dates tall guys and i'm
five foot and three fourths
five
five oh five sev bruce they cut off the
five seven and three fourths okay okay
i feel like this was god's only mistake
my vibe and persona is at least six
three and i am not
my question is uh our height preference
is just something i should accept when i
meet babes or is height discrimination
wrong and is this just a total shallow
harlot who will end up marrying a washed
up nba player on his fifth try
sincerely your other under six foot
brother
nick i you know that was one of the
cleaner messages you've sent into i
don't know is nick even just one person
or have has the audience just started
channeling the spirit of nick and
they're all i don't know maybe it's just
one guy
um
to your question nick
heightism
is look i say i'm not i'm not 6'3 i'm
not a basketball player okay
i say this
in a spirit of love
heightism is just something you're gonna
have to deal with buddy you know i think
actually your view i can't believe i'm
saying this your view on this is
actually probably pretty good maybe the
good lord didn't make you six four nick
because you're such a lothario you're so
impressive you're obviously
god's gift to women uh by your own
telling that it was just a it's a little
hurdle to to level out the playing field
make it fair recognizing that suffering
can be a very sanctifying event i think
you could probably use a little
sanctification nick but maybe maybe
you're on the right track
i'm glad you like that clip i like that
clip too i want i want to see you more
often i miss you i want you to see these
clips more often the way to do it is to
ring that bell
subscribe
or if you sometimes youtube even when
you do subscribe doesn't send you the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review you will get
the new episodes uncensored unvarnished
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]